hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today's lesson is going to be
about a poisonous plant known as
pokeweed you might recognize the
pokeweed from the berries in the picture
behind
me uh so let us
go ahead
and talk about what poke weed is
so this video is going to be about the
development of poke weed basically i
found some growing in my garden and i
thought it was cool and i learned about
it and i'm going to share that with you
today so the species name is phytolacca
americana and it's most uh
most well recognized i think by those
dark dark berries i am going to add a
little bit of a caveat today the
material provided in this video is for
educational purposes only that is
because this thing is poisonous and i'm
going to tell you that some people do
eat it with proper cooking i do not
recommend it educational purposes only
okay so pokeweed pokeweed it creates a
poisonous toxin it is very very
poisonous okay
to mammals and particularly of course
that does include humans
so the toxin is a violent a medic what
does that mean it induces vomiting um if
death occurs yes it can be lethal or you
know lethal fatal
so that's usually due to respiratory
paralysis
and there is a toxicity scale like the
roots are actually the most toxic so the
roots have the most toxin and are the
most deadly followed by the stems then
the leaves then the unripe berries then
the ripe berries
and the you know i do want to say like
the right berries can still be very
dangerous i mean children have died from
eating a few ripe berries so please
treat them with caution
so in the early spring
the shoots and the leaves not the root
okay that's important not the root
from less mature plants are edible with
proper cooking
i am not going to advise you on what
that means um i'm going to advise you
not to do it right don't eat this stuff
this stuff
this is why if you live in the american
south you may have heard of pope salad
some people
will get the shoots in the leaves and
cook it properly
and eat it as poke salad
it can still be deadly there have been
cases of adults being poisoned because
they harvested a little bit of the root
when they meant to get this other stuff
so
don't eat the stuff that's my
recommendation
this is a quote from the ohio
agricultural research and development
center
children are most frequently poisoned by
eating raw berries
infants are especially sensitive and
have died from eating only a few raw
berries adults have also been poisoned
sometimes fatally by eating improperly
prepared leaves and shoots especially if
part of the root is harvested with the
shoot that's what i was saying before
also by mistaking the root for some kind
of edible tuber or vegetable
research with humans has also shown that
common poke can cause mutations now this
was interesting to me because in all of
the places i saw where people were
talking about eating it um nobody was
talking about cancer but potentially
cancer and birth defects could be a
result of mutations so again just don't
eat this stuff
um since the juice of the poke weed can
be absorbed through the skin contact
of plant parts with bare skin should
also be avoided so when i was handling
this plant i always had my gardening
gloves on
so some other interesting facts it has
many many names american poke weed is
what i call it i think that's the most
common but also poke salad that's like
from the poke salad dragonberries
inkberry pop root virginia poke
pigeon berry red weed red ink plant
you'll see this inkberry and red ink
plant is because there was a time when
the berries were actually used to create
some some ink like ink for writing
this right here is not poke weed from my
garden this is what i saw when i was on
a walk with my kids and i was like wait
mama's gotta film some pokeberries um so
it was this big big cluster of them and
here you can see like some of the
unripened green berries and the ripe uh
like dark purple or blackberries
it does have a long history of use in
food and in folk remedies
i've even seen
other videos on youtube talking about
using it for like poultices and that
kind of thing not something i have any
expertise in and not something that i
plan to be doing anytime
in the future
something that is interesting i think is
that birds are immune to this poison and
so
the berries can frequently be eaten by
songbirds
let's talk about some physical
characteristics of pokeweed it can grow
up to 10 feet
the most common height is sort of four
to six feet in some places i saw three
three feet mentioned
so but it can get quite high and the
flowers have four to five sepals so the
sepals here are the kind of white things
and this is actually a photograph from
the one that i found growing in my
garden and instead of yanking it up i
decided to
just kind of keep an eye on it and make
some observations and share it with all
of you
so
i think it's really cool pokeweed
it
does not have any petals so its flowers
are comprised just of the sequels so
here you've got this kind of white sepal
the little green
um sphere in the middle is the ovary
uh and then you've got this this kind of
stem like structure that they're growing
on is called the peduncle
the sort of white connections between
the sepals and the peduncle are called
the pedestal
but the sepals they kind of do look like
little flowers now i just want to make
sure you understand what i mean by
steeples versus petals this is actually
a rose that's from you know rose bush in
my garden the petals are the pink
structures the green structures here are
the sepals so in pokeweed they only have
the sepals no petals pretty cool
poke weed is also a perennial it will
grow from roots each year so basically
every year at the end of the season
anything that's above the ground will
die so all of the
sort of branches and and berries and all
of that will dry up and die when winter
comes but that root
uh can like re-spawn a new plant every
year
so it is a perennial coming back each
season
i've read that the the root is really
really deep and hard to remove i haven't
pulled mine yet but when i do i'm going
to be very very careful i'm going to dig
super deep and try to make sure i get
all of it just because of course the
berries are poisonous and i do have
small children so i really don't want it
to be growing each year especially if i
don't realize it's there
i found the first ripe berry after about
one month of observation so i took this
picture on july 28th this is the first
time i really noticed it kind of growing
back behind another bush
and like under a tree where i wasn't
really looking and so i'm not sure how
long it took to reach you know about a
foot tall is probably how tall it was
here by october sorry by august 31st a
little bit over a month later you can
see it's gotten a lot more leaves more
stems it's taller i'm having to hold it
up again i'm wearing my gardening gloves
i'm having to kind of hold it upright
because the weight of all these clusters
of berries there's at least four
clusters of berries there we're kind of
causing it to like sag down
but right here you see the very first
ripe berry and this is actually
um
we're gonna see in a in a few minutes
some better pictures of like the process
of this of these berries ripening
so here they are right here
notice that the part of the peduncle
that is connected to the main stem
that is the order in which these berries
mature
so you can see very early on we've got
the sepals with the little green ovaries
now the sepals have been shed and those
ovaries have gotten larger and this is
kind of what we call the berries
and then the first one to ripen is the
one that's closest to the main stem
down here being the bottom of the berry
cluster that's not connected to anything
else and then you see as we as the days
go by
we get more and more berries and finally
that very last unripe berry is the one
at the tip so that's like the direction
that they mature in
you can also kind of see the maturity of
the plant of course everyone's looking
at the the berry colors me included but
you can also look at the stem color we
see here we've got sort of green stems
here the stem is getting lighter here
the stem is sort of turning to like a
reddish brown and by the time we get
over here you see it's very kind of pink
red that's another hallmark of pokeweed
is how kind of pink or
red looking those those stems and
peduncles and pedestals all get
and this is kind of where we're at now
so this is what my poke weed looks like
um i did put this
uh trellis behind it and tied it to the
trellis because it just seemed to be
falling over so much
i'm not really sure that helped because
obviously all these other stems coming
off of it are still quite heavy with the
berries
but
um at some point when i've got you know
a nice weather on a weekend i am going
to go ahead and pull it out it's been
nice to observe but i like i said i have
kids and i don't want them to
accidentally eat the berries or
something
so that's it for our topic of poke weed
if you're interested in learning more
about some different things that i've
got in my garden i've got other videos
on everything from tiger moths to uh
tomato hook uh yeah tomato hook worms
beach blight aphid so check out some of
my other videos to kind of learn along
with me and thank you for watching
biology professor